horemia has very quickly worked up my
list of favorite anime currently airing
in winter 2021
and today i just thought i'd share well
why that is
it's really shaping up to be a great
slice of life and touching romance story
and usually in my videos i'm talking
about some renowned show you know
something that i think is severely
underrated and is top tier anime or
manga level content
which i don't necessarily think horimia
is i just think it's a really great
romance story
like three episodes in so if you're not
watching it i hope after this video that
you will be encouraged to do so
and if you're already watching to just
reaffirm what you know i guess
or to get you even more excited about
what is to come in my personal favorite
anime of this season
and what is likely to be a standout for
the rest of the year if my gut feeling
is right
but first if you enjoy content like this
and want me to cover more topical anime
you know seasonal shows or manga that
are currently being serialized
make sure to subscribe and comment below
what you want to see the support would
be much appreciated and
enjoy the video so the show follows a
high school girl and boy hori and mia
mora hori is a really popular girl
smart you know the typical no faults
loved by everyone girl in class
she's honestly great wife of material
tori is in my opinion 2021's mizuhara
if you didn't watch rent a girlfriend
last year when that came out that's okay
the main protagonist of that anime was
pretty scummy so if you're gonna watch
anything just watch horimia instead
where the main protagonist isn't scummy
miyamura is kind of the loner in class
he's got this really long black hearing
glasses he visually meets the stereotype
of like the kid at the top of the class
who only cares about school
but if you thought that then you'd be
way off from the mark and that's where
the premise
of the show comes in miyamura behind the
curtain is actually like this really
edgy kid with tattoos and piercings
the reason he has such long hair is
actually to cover up the number of
piercings lying his ears
he's not even that good at school either
like most other students in the show
think
and he's really just an introverted guy
who can't express you know what he
enjoys at school because he didn't get
in trouble with teachers
if you're unfamiliar with japanese
standards for high schoolers or
students in general piercings especially
multiple and tattoos above even that are
a no-go
and hori is actually very different from
the ideal girl she's made out to be just
like miyamura is different from his
stereotype
back home because both of her parents
are always very busy she basically plays
the role of a stay-at-home mom to her
younger brother
she has to run to get eggs for cooking
after school and take care of her
brother about all the time so she can't
hang out with the cool kids
then one day through certain
circumstances myanmar finds sota
hori's younger brother when he's in
trouble and drops him off at their house
miyamura at the time of course has his
hair up and piercings on full display
because well no one's going to recognize
him here right but then bam
and comes hori and what happens from
here is essentially the story of these
two sharing their hidden lives with each
other and spending a lot of time
together
through you know the secret they have
they form a really special bond
and of course problems arise from this
like miyamura being worried over what
horry will look like when she's seen
hanging out with the weird quiet kid in
class
as well as what happens when they have
to explain what their relationship even
is
because it is a weird relationship
myanmar's main reason for coming over is
because sota the younger brother
takes a liking to him almost immediately
and becomes like an older brother
position in the household
but they both realize after a bit of
time that they don't want to just hide
their private lives for their own sake
but perhaps because myanmar and hori
don't want to affect the kind of
mysterious relationship blossoming
between them
but the show is only three episodes in
and i personally don't think that three
episodes is enough to gauge how good an
anime is
i think you can certainly tell whether
an anime is interesting or whether it
will probably be good
but to give an accurate rating of a show
at this point would be just inaccurate
and kind of rushing i feel just because
of how much happens after the three
episode point
so i read a little bit into the manga
and no i'm not gonna spoil
i just wanted to do it to make sure you
know my expectations were right
whether i could actually give an
educated take on horimia for this video
and
put my stamp of approval on it as one of
the best potentially of 2021
and i can the anime has actually gotten
pretty far
and episode 3 was already really good
like the level of relationship
development
we got here was yes
[Music]
but yeah i can confirm you know with the
way it's adapting the manga it'll be
great
and i really like the main character
miyamura maybe because oftentimes the
guy in these kinds of situations when
they're met with the really popular
dynamic girl
are really timid and afraid to speak up
which miyamura kind of is
but he has a much deeper character than
that you know stemming from being
bullied as a kid which led him to kind
of rebel and get piercings and tattoos
and never really finding a need to speak
his mind
but you know behind that which is a
really important part of this show not
judging books by their cover
he's just a really sweet kid who
actually puts others almost always
before himself
the reason he was always quiet is mainly
not to bother anyone
and so we see this really difficult
situation between myanmar and hori where
he's almost
so nice to her willing to do so much for
her
not necessarily romantically but because
myanmar values his friends very much
that he's actually afraid to get too
close to her because of how it'll look
to others and probably negatively affect
tory's status in school
and this frustrates hori actually
because she's a very straightforward
person and doesn't really mind
appearances like that
probably because of the very independent
life she's had to live so far
but luckily unlike many other anime pro
tags miyamora isn't super dense
thank god so you don't have to like
cringe as he tries to understand
everything he did wrong
he grasps it pretty quickly and the same
goes for hori
if she does anything wrong which is
bound to happen as two people get closer
in an anime
i mentioned this earlier but it's just a
very interesting kind of back and forth
between the lives when they interact in
school with other students
and when they're you know at home with
sota and kind of living as what very
quickly becomes a family type situation
horimia is looking to be really good and
considering how weak 2020 was
honestly in terms of anime and the fact
that 2021 is dominated already by a load
of just sequels
it's nice to get a fresh new anime like
this to start the year off right
i think it'll be the rent-a-girlfriend
of 2021
except you know better in just about
every way since myanmar is
actually cool and hori is a better waifu
than mizuhara
they ask you how you are you just have
to say that you're fine when you're not
really fun
anyway this has been the anime culture
corner i hope you enjoyed the video
don't forget to like and subscribe for
future in-depth show manga and character
analyses